[Music]
in cartel clothing news no they got
merged dope submitted by couples family
is working on a clothing line with his
branding oh no I like the way you say
old chocolate shop oh that's cool right
yeah but I don't know my whole family
all say el chapo chapter I'm assuming
this is a way to move more stuff this is
the cover for something oh that's smart
believe it I wouldn't be surprised at
this clothing line blew the [ __ ] up
though cuz you know just that song with
the game and I love that song such a
huge icon I think any merchandise that's
tight so he's like the Michael Jackson
of drug dealers dude he's like the
Escobar of today yeah to own a piece of
it and then rocked it and feel like
you're part of a bad stuff but it's
horrible stuff whose fanciful I mean who
stands who's uh who's more powerful is
it Escobar and his easier they're saying
that his peak I think he was making like
hundred million a week
what dog Bob yeah it was stupid
he bought a million dollars worth of
rubber bands a week just to tie his
money yeah what all the times el chapo
escaped and she was pretty
that's pretty legendary even burn money
to survive no Escobar [ __ ] had his own
prison though right true yes negotiated
with the government even to build your
own sick ass prison that's a go she with
the government that's licensed and they
would card in like [ __ ] and [ __ ] and
just have like liquor parties bar that
had the zoo also Lee had a bunch of
exotic animals got a submarine and [ __ ]
you can name anything and I would say
yes
it sounds like an epic Rap Battles by
the hand you're right about everything
right what an ass come on I would love
that are they still around I think so
yeah I think I'd rather she be like is
always deal
rap battle of jail against
whoo-whoo-whoo to be [ __ ] that's the
shortest rap battle ever I'm gonna go yo
what's up I like the orange door hinge
working on this for a long time good you
get one more door hinge door hinge now
chorus chorus just repeat chorus forever
and then get my ears out
Oh tapas wife who is had no idea he was
doing drugs apparently nice huh she put
out she says she had no idea that he was
a drug dealer
wouldn't you what's a good woman it's
just like I had no idea there's all this
stuff was illegal
she's like you're telling me elephant
smuggling is also family works in the
cartel with him yeah she's a down-ass
[ __ ] she's like I don't know and then
like a [ __ ] bag of cocaine falls over
so she's like that's not sounding good
Phoenix he's a guy's man couple mean why
did I call Matt up I wrote short short
oh okay I'm not with something more
badass but you know in this case it's
still about us please don't kill how
short he is I look crazy like he's spoke
with the choreo I think he just looks
really handsome guys 29 year old Emma
Coronel how come these pictures look
like they were taken in the 80s I know
kind of weird so they have seven year
old twin daughters together oh I'd be so
sure she's been married to him since she
was 18
Oh what Evan teen or 16 oh wow listen to
these fools talking [ __ ] on El Chapo I'm
not touching it
I think he's I'm staying over I mean
I would [ __ ] all troppo there you go hi
David so company I'm not talking [ __ ]
alright you can find me at David so call
me Graham James so company on Twitter I
am NOT talking [ __ ] [ __ ] you old chapo
I think I'm not David so comedy anymore
do you like to come on the podcast yeah
so now they're saying that emma is going
to be the one behind this whole new
clothing line cuz she is in love with
fashion and all that stuff like that's
her thing and they said that they had
been talking about this idea of
launching a clothing line for many years
and so finally El Chapo they've saved
enough money to do this yeah that's nice
while he's in prison they sign he signed
away his rights from his like to his
name and his signature to this LLC
called jgl LLC and they're just pretty
much saying that hopefully by the summer
they will be launching like shirts and
hats and I know a bunch of planks Jesus
man she loves fashion but she's putting
up link imagine imagine like they're so
[ __ ] rich it doesn't matter if they
make a profit everything's lined with
gold well once you make ten million a
week doesn't really matter what it is
right she can put out absolute garbage
be like you could take both sides of the
issue
he should have shirts that say jail el
chapo or like free El Chapo elbow you're
a businessman aren't you but that's like
an actual way to mark people so his
people find anyone that's buying that
jail El Chapo [ __ ] and just kill them
and they know where they live because
they had their addresses and [ __ ] cuz
we're shipping so there is this law or
like these laws called Son of Sam laws
which were created to prevent criminals
from profiting off helliya publicity
gained from their high that's
interesting whoa [ __ ] tell it to
Bonnie and Clyde do you know I don't
think they did
whoever made the movies and stuff Dave I
don't think they directly could yeah so
it's been like directly they can't
profit and so um they did create this
LLC in New York so because of that
authorities could seize assets from that
company even if it's his wife that's
profiting from it yeah good they're
using his name
and like his fame for the like entire
clothing line so that song El Chapo it's
okay because they're not gonna pay him
royalties exactly she's not profiting
off of that but because she's like his
family you know and like they're married
and their daughters and all that stuff
um I wonder if she'll ever be able to
marry anyone else ever did but no no huh
no you can't wake up next to a tiger and
then let me go the next day absolutely
what if she needs to get laid though I
don't know I don't want to know is that
when you have 24 carat [ __ ] vibrators
probably does it really help solid
diamond I don't know no it just goes
dancer girlfriend like no I mean like it
would help if I knew I was rich as [ __ ]
and a full diamond vibrator your riches
[ __ ] you can afford a dick vibrator yeah
this is the guy shakey Jorge how
expensive would a guy be give me a break
bro Jesus dude I went to what was I I
was at my dentist office and my dentist
comes over he's like you've had some
work done I was like what the [ __ ] ain't
no words I'm out getting like turning 38
and there was this guy sitting across
from me like this older black guy he's
like I just turned 60 and I look great
and then like I was like holy [ __ ] you
don't look like he turned 60 and then he
was like telling me like life advice
about you know don't worry about getting
older bubble blah like for me like all
about life was me getting money living
Liam just enjoy my life I don't need no
dick like some dudes want to ruin my
life would dick and I just tell them and
he goes honey I can pay $250 for some
dick [ __ ] for like an hour and a half
and then go about my way I don't need a
man I was just like wow yeah so 200 it
always is apparently how much a man call
sounds $150 sounds expensive it's kind
of you get a guy way cheaper than that
[ __ ] are you kidding me [ __ ]
milkshake dude I don't think you be
money guys guys that's a buck we can't
wait to [ __ ] ya it's not gonna be hard
to get it out I think she hasn't figured
it out yet
no right one of my exact houdina yeah
yeah she's comforted I was a dude oh the
dude it was a gay guy Oh
you were wearing a different yeah we
thought it was a lady I like you know I
was like wait she's meeting her guy yeah
give me a [ __ ] gay guys in consoled
way more oh that makes sense a lot more
than the world make sense now son what
makes if you were gay
still it meets it cost a lot more I mean
if it was gay still no no no oh the
comic was put in the wrong place he
wouldn't have paid way more than 250 to
[ __ ] a [ __ ] and I was like but what if
you were gay it would still got it I
think that what Bart's saying is that
gay guys have standards and I don't
think a lot of straight guys do oh yeah
absolutely
thanks a lot more to barda's high
standards very high standards I just I
strongly disagree no they're very
there's the highest the evidence speaks
otherwise I'm willing to hear your
sources hello look here this right here
so there's a love we can we can agree
yeah we can we don't you wear glasses I
I do there you go I should as he leaves
and crushes cards inside walls I know as
long as I get outta here before dusk
I'll be okay
the lawyers they're saying like well
chuckle who's not gonna profit from
anything this is solely Emma's project
mm-hmm oh no he's not getting profit
whatever shall he do is all of his
assets seized I highly doubt it
he's hidden a lot of money yeah can we
cut to El Chapo in jail right now
getting like carried around on a chair
holding chariot what does it matter
he is killing it there dude no doubt my
[ __ ] slicing apples and putting in
his mouth right now chairs what a
picture didn't like a bunch of dudes
just carrying around his [ __ ] slices
yeah no doubt
no no well then gold night am I supposed
to feel bad for somebody right now no I
mean he's the king of the jail no doubt
there's a dude that got out of jury duty
and his uh his his his court case cuz he
went up to the garden said oh my god
I'll chop what do you think get it I can
get an autograph and because of that
like all right you can't be on Jerry day
because you're a bias and I was like
you're so [ __ ] smart I would be
terrified to be on that jerk yeah don't
kill myself I would be like I love El
Chapo he's my favorite I just don't want
to be on jury duty ever dude no I just
got out of it you did yeah what'd you do
I told him I was busy with work that's
it
he's right that [ __ ] in there like so
what so the [ __ ] what so if they usually
tell everyone yeah they were like Oprah
was here right [ __ ] Oprah ruined it
for everyone no bomb Obama did it - yeah
well cuz Obama did jury duty yeah man he
did jury duty yeah the [ __ ] president
the United States no no but now that
he's not president he deserves a former
president you're a criminal in the court
case and you look over and [ __ ] Obama
sitting there in the jury panel do Danny
and imagine he's trying to get out of it
he's got a copy of mine comp and he's
like yeah [ __ ] yeah anybody seeing me
reading this dude I had to do it and of
course I didn't get picked for a trial
so you just basically just bring a book
and just sit there and read all day with
mouth-breathers all around you yep it's
so sad and boring yeah I brought my
Nintendo switch to look like a
degenerate can I have your phone on you
issue yeah it's basically like you're at
the DMV
it was orientation or whatever literally
you're at the DMV I've never been to
jury duty what do you mean you were in
the military what do you have to say to
not be on jury duty let's say you get
called in and they you don't want to be
a part of it you said say listen I you
can't hate chinks tanks they're like oh
don't worry cuz the guy on trials white
and then you like man hockey's English
with a woman that would knows like I am
such a big fan
David so how are you kill you you have
to like have a reason like you have to
you're a caretaker or sole caretaker for
someone or like I think it's a
legitimate excuse because if I'm the
only person doing my work and you take
me out for a whole week then you better
[ __ ] compensate me for the work they
don't owe they pay you gas or some [ __ ]
yeah yeah self-employment [ __ ] - like
what what hours do you work in Chile
yeah $4,000 a week how about that dude I
would show up in a full civil war outfit
with the southern flag Confederates we
have it lost that's right you
misunderstood the Confederate flag
[Music]